[Aplausos]
cuando estaba construyendo esta charla
pensé en hablar acerca de mi vocación
pensé en hablar sobre algo que me
expusiera un poquito menos pero luego me
di cuenta que este mensaje va mucho más
allá de mí y va mucho más allá de mis
miedos luego me encontré en internet lo
siguiente
y espero me pongan
esta es una nota sacada de excélsior que
dice que en méxico los suicidios entre
jóvenes y niños están potenciando a
causa del bullying a causa del acoso
escolar y la asociación mexicana de
psiquiatría la asociación nacional de
psiquiatría dice que si la situación
continúa así para el 2020 seguramente
este va a ser el primer motivo por
muertes de niños y adolescentes y me
parece muy triste porque seguí buscando
y encontré que en 5 años mataron a 381
personas miembros de la comunidad lgbt
en nuestro país 381 personas que
pudieron haber sido padres madres amigos
y hace no más de tres meses asesinaron a
una mujer transexual en su propia casa
en nuevo león
en hidalgo en mi estado
y tres años van más de 500 casos de
violencia escolar y este año golpearon
salvajemente a una niña de secundaria
mientras le gritaban no sirves para nada
y
esa frase me dolió mucho me dolió como
si me lo hubieran dicho a mí porque en
algún momento me dijeron que no servía
para nada por ser homosexual que era un
raro que no tenía nada que hacer que mi
opinión no valía que mis sueños no eran
valiosos que mejor me callara
y eso me parece profunda profundamente
triste
[Música]
yo crecí en un lugar en el que
la violencia hacia las mujeres es pan de
cada día es algo que está normalizado la
violencia doméstica en el que siendo
homosexual estás condenado a ser el
circo del pueblo estás condenado a que
te digan cosas sin ningún derecho en la
calle que te señalen que se burlen de ti
que te exhiban
y debo confesar que en algún momento me
dio miedo de que ese fuera mi destino me
sentía mal conmigo mismo me sentía mal
con lo que era porque pensaba que no
estaba haciendo bien las cosas que no
estaba haciendo como la sociedad en la
que vivía me pedía que fuera
afortunadamente a lo largo de mi vida me
he topado con personajes que me
inspiraron y que me enseñaron que hay
gente maravillosa alrededor del mundo
que hay gente que no tiene miedo a ser
diferente que no tiene miedo a la
crítica
y que levanta la voz para decir que no
entendía una ronda verse que es una de
las atletas más grandes del mundo que
todos los días recibe hate en sus redes
sociales de personas diciéndole que
tiene un cuerpo demasiado masculino
cuando ella trabaja todos los días para
ser un atleta de alto rendimiento y
demostrar que el poder de una mujer no
está en una falda en un vestido también
entendió freddie mercury que para su
época consiguió ser una revolución en la
música hizo lo que quiso vivió como
quiso se vistió como quiso hizo lo que
le dio la gana
entendió un barack obama que es el
primer presidente afroamericano de los
estados unidos- y que puso el tema de la
diversidad sobre la mesa
entendía un alan estrada que es un
bloguero mexicano que además de
documentar sus viajes y sus experiencias
invita a la gente a vivir de la manera
que le dé la gana de la manera que lo
haga feliz sin importar lo que otros
piensen o digan con guillermo del toro
que está abriendo brechas para todos los
latinos en el mundo entero y está
rompiendo paradigmas de cómo nos ven a
los mexicanos con una manera
extraordinaria para mostrar la belleza
aún en los lugares más oscuros
tuve que decir que no tuve que decirle
que no a la gente que me preguntaba si
mi homosexualidad era reversible como si
se tratara de una gripa una gripa que me
ha durado 24 años entonces tuve que
decir que no a toda la gente que empezó
a cuestionar si lo que yo hacía estaba
bien o no que me dijo no es no no actúes
no hagas esto no hagas el otro no sirve
para eso dedícate a otra cosa no salgas
de tu casa no dejes ese trabajo que no
te gusta no no no
y habría sido muy fácil darme por
vencido y comprarles esas ideas
pero no es así entonces un día llego a
mi casa a un departamento que rentaba
donde me estaban esperando mis caseros
las las personas dueñas del lugar y me
estaban esperando para correr me porque
yo no tenía para pagar la renta
acaba de terminar una relación en la que
al parecer yo no había sido suficiente
no quería pedirle ayuda a mis papás
llega que estaba muy estresado y muy
frustrado por estar en un trabajo que si
bien no era malo pues no era mi lugar y
no me hacía feliz entonces llega a la
casa mis caseros me esperaban para
recorrer me y les pedí un momento que me
dejaran un momento para empacar en
realidad quería llorar solas pero cuando
me di cuenta que las cosas me estaban
rebasando y empecé a pensar escucho una
gotera en el baño y voy a tratar de
arreglarla y pues con mis conocimientos
en plomería no son los mejores pues
rompí la tubería y de repente había
mucha agua estaba todo inundado no sabía
si eran mis lágrimas o era el agua del
baño entonces me subí a mí eso te a
tratar de cerrar la llave y todo todo
salió peor
me quedé sentado en la azotea
y el cielo es un recurso y me di cuenta
que tenía muchas posibilidades que no
podía permitir que mi valor se definiera
por otros y que había pasado mucho
tiempo de mi vida tratando de convencer
a otros de que era valioso había pasado
mucho tiempo de mi vida tratando de
llenar las expectativas de otros y las
mías se quedaban al final
y me cansé ese día me prometí que nunca
más iba a dejar que alguien
me limitará que no iba a vivir para
satisfacer a mi trabajo a mi familia a
una pareja a lo que la sociedad esperaba
de mí si no iba a empezar a cumplir mis
propias expectativas me di cuenta
también de que tengo una responsabilidad
muy grande porque ser parte de un grupo
vulnerable no es solamente tener un
color de piel tener una preferencia
sexual ser mujer o no va más allá
yo tengo algo que hacer con eso
ok soy gay bien qué haces con eso te
pones a llorar y dices pobrecito de mí
porque me discriminan y me hablan mal en
la calle y la gente espera muy poco de
mí
tomar acción y decidir que era mi
responsabilidad ser un vocero y ayudar a
mi comunidad es lo que me llevó a tomar
una decisión entonces renunció a mi
trabajo
la historia comienza
no sé qué pasó pero de pronto empezaron
a salir muchas cosas y he tenido la
oportunidad de hablar de estos temas en
varios centros educativos de mi estado
estoy haciendo una película estoy
empezando a hacer teatro tengo proyectos
en puerta y la importancia no es porque
sean muchos
lo importante es que decidí creer en mí
y decidí respetarme porque no podemos
esperar que el respeto primero venga de
afuera el respeto tiene que venir de
adentro y si tú no te respetas lo que
eres tus creencias tus sueños
más allá afuera
más importante
el amor propio
y una vez que comencemos a amarnos vamos
a ser capaces de poner altos de decir
que no
civilizar
a veces la gente no se da cuenta del
daño que puede provocar el bullying o el
acoso
duele de verdad que duele la violencia
en pareja la violencia en las mujeres
duele y lastima no olvidemos que
tratamos con seres humanos y que esos
seres humanos pueden ser tu hermana tu
mamá tu hijo y creo que el escenario
sería completamente diferente nadie
tiene derecho a hacer sentir mal a otro
por ser quien es
hace no mucho que una película que se
llama the greatest showman en la que
hicieron una frase que me
no se me dejó me dijo pensando muchas
cosas y la frase dice
no van a verme de diferentes bingley
everyone else nadie ha hecho a una
diferencia siendo como los demás
entonces por qué condenamos la
diferencia
porque la sufrimos porque le tenemos
miedo a lo que no es igual a nosotros y
porque lo juzgamos si la riqueza de esta
vida que está en las diferencias
y eso me lleva
a pensar que venimos aquí para vivir
para amar y para sentir en voz alta no
somos una cara bonita no somos una
religión no somos una preferencia sexual
no somos que si estás muy gordito que si
estás muy flaquito bueno somos más que
eso somos seres humanos
y lo único que necesitamos es un poquito
de valentía
pero esa valentía
más de gays los de mujeres no se
transexuales no es afroamericanos no es
de latinos
la valentía
es de seres humanos
que toman sus diferencias su identidad
su amor propio
y así mismos
se abrazan con mucha fuerza salen al
mundo defenderse
y se atreven a decir que no gracias
[Aplausos]